der Tod jeevgeni prigoschens hat und das
mag jetzt etwas untertrieben klingen
einen wahren Wendepunkt für die
wagnergruppe markiert die gescheiterte
Meuterei im vergangenen Juli ist für ihn
letztendlich tödlich ausgegangen der
Anführer der berühmtesten zöldnergruppe
seit den Film von syvester stalone hat
sein Machtspiel verloren und sich mit
dem falschen Mann angelegt Vladimir
Putin der Kremmel wirft einen langen
Schatten und um die Nachfolge von
Herrschern wie Simeon dem stolzen und
Ivan dem schrecklichen anzutreten
braucht man eine große Portion Wagemut
und persönliches Ego und der derzeitige
Zar von Russland und kolonisator der
Ost- und Südukraine hat mehr als genug
Verdienste gesammelt um als Vladimir der
rachsüchtige in die Geschichte
einzugehen prgosens Rechnung für seinen
Marsch auf Moskau ist bereits beglichen
und diesmal gab es kein Trinkgeld nach
heftiger Kritik gegenüber der
Kriegsführung des kremmels stand die
wagnergruppe kurz vor der Auflösung und
trat am 3 2 juni 2023 dann noch mal ins
Rampenlicht jeevgeni prigosen und sein
Team forderten das
Verteidigungsministerium und den Kremmel
heraus aber ihr Marsch für Gerechtigkeit
wurde geblockt nach dem Vorfall zeigte
sich Wladimir Putin sichtlich entrüstet
über den Akt des Verrats und schwor die
Verantwortlichen zur Verantwortung zu
ziehen zunächst hielt er den Ball noch
flach um all seine Schäfchen ins
Trockene zu bringen aber dann hat er
getreut diesem seinen Wort mit seinen
Aktionen alle Zweifel an seiner Haltung
ausgeräumt es ist klar dass er die
Söldnergruppe mittlerweile gemäß seinen
Wünschen umgeformt hat die Anführer
haben Putin ihre Loyalität bewiesen sie
kämpfen weiterhin weltweit für ihr Land
aber doch ganz anders als früher trotz
einer Säuberungsaktion überlebte Wagner
wurde zerteilt untersteht jetzt
teilweise der Nationalgarde der
Russischen Föderation und um den schönen
Schein zu warahen wurde der 25-Jährige
Sohn prgorens Pavel als neuer
proformaanführer der Truppe installiert
denn noch meine Lieben visualpolitik
Zuschauer gibt es noch viele
unbeantwortete Fragen zur Zukunft der
der wagnergruppe sie hat ihr prominentes
Gesicht verloren aber es gibt immer noch
tausende von zöldnern die in
verschiedenen Ländern vor allem Afrika
eingesetzt werden nun nach dem
anfänglichen Schock scheint das Bild
angesichts von schlagzeahen wie dieser
langsam klarer zu werden russische
privatmilitärfirmen wollen Wagner
kampfchats übernehmen alles Deut darauf
hin dass der Kremmel stark daran
interessiert ist Wagners Erfolge in
Afrika zu erhalten zu diesem zeig ist es
wahrscheinlich dass auch andere
sonderergruppen mit bemerkenswerten
Verbindungen zum russischen
Verteidigungsministerium und zum
russischen Geheimdienst einen großen
Teil des bisher von Wagner aufgebauten
Imperiums kontrollieren werden ihr kennt
das Sprichwort the winner takes it all
dem Sieger gehört die Beute und sicher
kennt ihr auch das andere släbe geht
weiter aber jetzt haltet euch fest denn
es gibt eine Gruppe unnachgiebiger
russische Söldner die sich nicht
beherrschen lassen wollen und die bereit
sind für das Überleben des
ursprünglichen Geistes von Wagner zu
kämpfen die Frage ist also wie wird es
wirklich mit der wagnergruppe
weitergehen auf welche Weise wird der
Kremmel versuchen die vielfältigen
Vorteile die Wagners Aktivitäten für die
russische Außenpolitik bieten in den
Griff zu bekommen in der heutigen
Ausgabe von visualpolitik werden wir all
diese Fragen beantworten und zwar wieeso
oft indem wir zunächst einen schnellen
Blick in die Geschichte werfen bevor wir
dies tun habe ich euch noch eine frohe
Botschaft zu überbringen das heutige
Video hat nämlich incogni möglich
gemacht ein Sponsor euch aktiv vor
Datenmissbrauch durch sogenannte
databoker schützen kann ihr wisst nicht
was das ist nun das ist ein großer
Fehler databoker sind nämlich
datenmarkler die unsere persönlichen
Daten überall im Netz ab greifen und
danach nicht nur an seriöse Unternehmen
verkaufen sondern auch an Betrüger diese
Betrüger bombardieren uns dann mit
unerwünschten Anrufen SMS und E-Mails
oder versuchen uns sogar auszunehmen
Nachteile durch die Verbreitung deiner
Daten müssen dir aber gar nicht erst
durch betrüge erwachsen hast du dir
schon mal überlegt wer alles aus diesen
Daten Rückschlüsse ziehen könnte
teilweise sind sie ja sogar falsch oder
verfälscht oder können eine
Fehlinterpretation deines Verhaltens im
Netz darstellen und dann wunderst du
dich warum du z.B vom neuen Arbeitgeber
oder Vermieter abgelehnt wirst plötzlich
höhere Versicherungsbeiträge zahlen
musst oder kein Kredit von der Bank
bekommst und zwar ohne jemals den wahren
Grund dafür zu erfahren genau leider
haben wir keinerlei Kontrolle darüber an
wen alles die databoker unsere Daten
verkaufen und was Ihre Kunden dann
daraus gegen uns stricken aber es gibt
zum Glück einen Ausweg aus diesem
Albtraum die databoker sind nämlich
gesetzlich dazu verpflichtet unsere
Daten zu löschen wenn wir sie dazu
auffordern okay Problem gelöst wir
können weitermachen tja wenn es so
einfach wäre es gibt nämlich 1000 von
diesen databokern und oft ist der
Antragsprozess zum Löschen absichtlich
kompliziert gestaltet und genau deswegen
resignieren viele Menschen einfach und
lassen den ganzen Schmu passiv über sich
ergehen der Sponsor dieses Videos
incogni bietet jedoch genau dafür eine
Lösung incogni übernimmt die Aufgabe bei
den datokern aufzuräumen und die
Löschanträge zu stellen um uns vor
Betrugsversuchen zu schützen du meldest
dich einfach bei incogn an beauftragt
sie in deinem Namen die Löschanträge
durchzusetzen und verfolgst dann bequem
auf einem übersichtlichen Dashboard wie
deine Daten na nach und nach aus dem
Netz verschwinden ohne einen solchen
Service wäre es für normalen Menschen
nahzu unmöglich all diese Löschanträge
selbst zu bearbeiten und dann juristisch
durchzusetzen aber selbst das macht
incogni jetzt also tu was gutes für
deine datenhygiene und schau dir incogni
über den Link in der Videobeschreibung
jetzt an außerdem mit dem promokode
politikde er hältst du auch noch 60%
Rabatt wenn du zu den ersten 100 gehörst
die ihn nutzen also nichts viel los
probier in cogni gleich aus und wenn du
dann wieder hier bist lass uns in die
Geschichte der wagnergruppe eintauchen
um so ihre Zukunft zu
ergründen die Methode
Wagner alles begann in der Ukraine vor
fast 10 Jahren Wagners Spur führt uns
zurück zum März 2014 als Russland die
Halbinsel Krim annektierte das war etwas
anderes als die aktuelle Invasion der
Ukraine damals kamen die berüchtigten
kleinrünen Männchen plötzlich aus dem
Nichts auf die Krim es handelte sich um
russische Soldaten ohne Abzeichen die
der Kremmel jedoch als Einheimische und
Urlaube ausgab Separatisten die mit der
russischen Sache sympathisierten es
wären Zivilisten die in diesem Gebiet am
Schwarzen Meer zu den Waffen gegriffen
hätten weil sie nicht länger Ukrainer
sein und sich der Russischen Föderation
anschließen wollten die Realität sah
natürlich ganz anders aus diese kleinen
grrünen Männchen waren eine Mischung aus
Agenten der Spezialkräfte und anderen
Einheiten des Militärgeheimdienstes der
russischen Streitkräfte sowie
vertragspersonal der wagnergruppe mit
anderen Worten eine Mischung aus Spiel
und Söldnern genau das was der Kremmel
brauchte um zu leugnen dass die kleinen
grünen Männchen dort direkt seine
Befehle ausführten die russische
Verfassung verbietet eigentlich die
Aufstellung privater bewaffneteer
Einheiten aber der Kremmel war sich ihre
enormen Vorteile schon immer bewusst die
glaubhafte bestreitbarkeit ist einer der
größten Vorteile privater
Militärfirmen sie bieten die Möglichkeit
dort einzugreifen wo Staaten nicht
offiziell handeln können und
anschließend können die Behörden immer
ab schreiten dass der Staat an den
Aktionen dieser Söldner beteiligt war
vor allem bei solchen die einen
ausgeprägten klandestinen Charakter
haben und außerdem zählen ihre Opfer
nicht und natürlich war das Gesetz für
Putin nie ein Hindernis im Kremmel
brauchten sie nur jemanden der kein
Problem damit hatte es zu umgehen einen
Oligarchen der im Verborgenen agiert um
eine scheinbar legale geschäftsfassade
für eine völlig illegale Aktivität zu
schaffen jemand der bereit ist sich an
die Vorgaben der Auftraggeber zu halten
die diese Art von Angelegenheiten
aushcken und wie wir bei visualpolitik
sagen schneller gesagt als getan ihr
Mann war jeevgeni prigosin Putins
Chefkoch und Besitzer des
Lieblingsrestaurants des russischen
Präsidenten durch lukrative
cateringverträge für die russische Armee
war dieser Milliardär geworden der
ideale Mann für Putin die gleichen
Männer wie auf der Krim tauchten dann
anschließend auch im Donbass und in
Syrien
[Musik]
auf Putin Söldner spielten auch eine
entscheidende Rolle bei der russischen
Invasion des donbas die auch als
separatistenkrieg getarnt war sie brach
anschließend gleich nach der annextion
der Krim aus Ende 2015 tauchten außerdem
Berichte über die Beteiligung russischer
Söldner am syrienkrieg zur Unterstützung
des Regimes von Bashar al-Assad auf es
war das erste Mal dass die wagnergruppe
die Formel von militärischen Diensten im
Tausch gegen natürliche Ressourcen
verwendete in diesem Fall im Tausch
gegen 25% der Einnahmen aus den vom
islamischen Staat zurückeroberten Öl und
gasförderfeldern dennoch ist Afrika der
Kontinent bei dem die Methode Wagner zur
Perfektion getrieben wurde nach den
Erfolgen in der Ukraine und in Syrien
begannen die russischen Diplomaten die
Dienste ihrre privaten Militärfirmen im
Umgang mit anderen Ländern anzubieten
und die wagnergruppe war ihr bester
Verkaufsartikel ihr erster Einsatz in
Afrika war im Libyenkrieg wo die
wagnergruppe in den Dienst des
rebellengeners Khalifa haftar gestellt
wurde die russischen Soldner boten
haftarstruppen Ausrüstung Ausbildung und
geheimoperationsdienste und erhielten im
Gegenzug Zugang zu lübischen Gas und Öl
in den letzten Jahren expandierte die
wagnergruppe in ein gutes Dutzend
afrikanischer Länder und verfolgt dabei
ein geschätzmodell das im wesentlichen
aus drei Elementen besteht dem
militärischen indem sie ihre Söldner als
Sicherheitsgarantie für das jeweils
herrschende Regime anbietet dem
politischen indem sie Propaganda und
Desinformationskampagne durchführt und
sogar gefälschte Gruppen von
Wahlbeobachtern organisiert wie z.B die
der Vereinigung afrik die bei
Abstimmungen in verschiedenen Ländern
wie Simbabwe Madagascar Kongo Südafrika
und Mosambik tätig war und schließlich
ist da noch das wirtschaftliche Element
das ist die Belohnung die diese Staaten
Wagner für ihre Dienste
anbieten aber wartet mal denn wenn es
einen Ort auf der Welt gibt an dem die
Tentakel der wagnergruppe ungeahnte
Ausmaße angenommen haben dann ist es
kein anderer als die Zentralafrikanische
Republik ihr Präsident forostin AR war
zwischen 2008 und 2013 Premierminister
Minister des Landes und wurde dann
abgesetzt und als er bei den
Präsidentschaftswahlen 2016 die Macht
ergriff muss tdera sich versprochen
haben dass niemand ihn jemals wieder
absetzen würde nicht einmal das
zentralafrikanische Volk selbst denn es
ist die eine Sache Wahlen zu gewinnen
aber eine ganz andere sie zu verlieren
und deswegen schlossen die
Zentralafrikanische Republik und
Russland 2018 mehrere bilaterale
Abkommen ab um offiziell militärische
Unterstützung und Waffen gegen
bergbaukonzession zu tauschen
anschließend wurde ein ehemaliger
Offizier des des russischen
Militärgeheimdienstes Valeri Sacharov
zum nationalen Sicherheitsberater von
Präsident t dera und Wagners Söldner
wurden Teil seiner persönlichen Eskorte
außerdem wird geschätzt dass die
wagnergruppe bis zu 2600 Kämpfer
einsetzte als bewaffnete Rebellengruppen
im Land auftauchten und seitdem hat der
russische Einfluss ein ungeahntes Maß
erreicht russisch wird zum Pflichtfach
an den Universitäten der
Zentralafrikanischen Republik leider ist
für die Zentralafrikanische Republik
eines der ärmsten Länder der Welt die
Kultur nicht der einzige Preis den sie
Russland zah zahlen muss der Machterhalt
Tour deras hat seinen Preis und der ist
nicht gerade billig die
Zentralafrikanische Republik hat Wagner
einen großen Teil ihrer natürlichen
Ressourcen zur Verfügung gestellt und
wollt ihr wissen wie profitabel es sein
kann Besitzer einer Söldnerarmee zu
werden dann passt jetzt mal gut
auf Gold für die
Kriegsmaschinerie es war vollkommen klar
dass Vladimir Putin sich prigoschen
Rechen will aber auch klar war dass er
alles andere als bereit ist alles
aufzugeben was Wagner für Russland
erreicht hat denn das war eine ganze
Menge Afrika ist für den Kremmel im
Moment äußerst wichtig es ist vor allem
deswegen wichtig um zu zeigen dass
Russland nicht isoliert ist wie es beim
Gipfel der führenden Politiker des
Kontinents Ende Juli in STT petersburg
versucht wurde und alles was Wagner in
Afrika erreicht hat hatte eine große
Wirkung zu geringen Kosten in den
Ländern in denen sie tätig sind tragen
sie z.B dazu bei antiest westliche
Botschaften zu verbreiten und wageners
Verbindungen zu afrikanischen
Kriegsherren könnten dazu beitragen dass
sich die Amtsträger dieser Staaten in
Zukunft besser mit Russland verstehen
außerdem was soll's die russischen
Söldner kontrollieren Projekte die
einfach zu profitabel sind um sie
aufzugeben das nennt man Kapitalismus
nach russischer Lesart
Leute die Zentralafrikanische Republik
hat Konzession für den Gold und
Diamantenabbau an Unternehmen vergeben
die mit der wagnergruppe verbunden sind
wie z.B Midas resources zu diesen
Anlagen gehört auch die andassima Mine
sie verfügt über Goldreserven im Wert
von mehr als einer Milliarde Dollar und
die Söldner können Sie 25 Jahre lang
Ausbeuten boarou ein weiteres
Unternehmen das mit brigoschen verbunden
war erhielt die Konzession zum Abholzen
mehrerer tropischer urwäer dies hat der
wagnergruppe ganz neue
Geschäftsmöglichkeiten eröffnet nämlich
die
Holzindustrie und ihr alle wisst wie der
Holzpreis in die Höhe geschossen ist ich
hoffe ihr versteht jetzt wie die
hunderten von tandfirmen der
wagnergruppe eine zentrale Rolle in der
Strategie des des Kremmel spielen um
Verbündete in Afrika zu gewinnen während
Russland sich ihrer Ressourcen
bemächtigt und neue Wege findet die
westlichen Sanktionen zu umgehen aber
unter all diesen ruhstoffen sticht vor
allem Gold hervor die
Zentralafrikanische Republik aber auch
andere Länder wie der Sudan erweisen
sich für den Kremmel als wichtige
goldgequelle denn die Goldreserven
helfen Russland die Auswirkung der
Sanktionen wegen des Krieges in der
Ukraine zu überstehen interessanterweise
kommt das afrikanische Gold oft über
denselben Zwischenstopp in Moskau an die
vereinigten arabischen Emirat denn trotz
der vom Westen verhängten Sanktionen
hält der Goldfluss nach Russland
weiterhin an eigenen Angaben zufolge
sind die russischen Goldreserven im
letzten Jahr sogar gestiegen im Jahr
2023 haben sie gar ein Allzeithoch
erreicht das könnt ihr der folgenden
Grafik entnehmen die vierteljährliche
Daten zu den russischen Goldreserven in
Tonnen über die letzten zwei Jahrzehnte
zusammenfasst darüber hinaus stellte ein
britischer parlamentsbericht vor zwei
Monaten fest dass der goldschmuggel dazu
beiträgt die russische Wirtschaft zu
stützen denn in der Zwischenzeit
funktioniert die Methode Wagner
weiterhin und be weiß dass sie eine
wahre Geldmaschine ist wollt ihr ein
weiteres konkretes
[Musik]
Beispiel nun in Mali wo nach zwei
Staatsstreichen den letzten Jahren eine
militärhunter regiert verlangt die
wagnerergruppe für ihre Dienste ein
monatliches Honorar von 10 Millionen
Euro komm schon nicht einmal Messi bei
Inter Miami bekommt so viel das Ziel der
russischen Söldner in Mali ist der Kampf
gegen dihadistische Gruppen die mit
al-Qaida und daes verbunden sind zu
diesem Zweck sind etwa 1600
wagnersoldaten vor Ort und die
militärhunter muss mit ihrer Arbeit
äußerst zufrieden sein denn sie hat die
französischen Truppen aus dem Land
vertrieben und nun werden die 13 000 un
Blauhelme abziehen nachdem die malische
Regierung selbst Sie dazu aufgefordert
hat denn die militärkunter hat sich für
ihren Ersatz bereits entschieden un
beendet Friedensmission in Mali
wagnergruppe füllt die Lücke zuvor hat
ein unbericht malischen Truppen und
russischen Söldnern vorgeworfen bei
einer Militäroperation im März 2022 mehr
als 500 Menschen getötet zu haben und
das Gefühl beobachtet zu werden ist
natürlich etwas das Diktaturen sehr
unangenehm ist viel besser ist es mit
Wagner zu arbeiten und das muss sich
auch Vladimir Putin gedacht haben als
die russische Bevölkerung ihren Unmut
über die teilmobilisierung für den Krieg
in der Ukraine zeigte allerdings war es
dem russischen Präsidenten nachdem sie
ihm jahrelang im Verborgenen gut gedient
hatten wichtig nach der Meuterei prosin
Rolle herunterz spielen er gab also
schließlich zu dass hinter Wagner
eigentlich der russische Staat Selb
steckt
государством из министерства обороны из
государственного бюджета мы полностью
финансировали эту группу с мая д вго
года по май рего на денежное содержание
и стимулирующие выплаты государство
заплатило компанияag
л als Messi da der ständig wachsende
ehgeistbgorans für den Kremmel jedoch zu
einem immer größeren Problem wurde gab
Putin schließlich dem eifersüchtigen
Verteidigungsministerium nach die
wagnergruppe sollte in die reguläre
Armee und in andere private
Militärunternehmen integriert werden die
anderen Oligarchen gehören und in diesem
Zusammenhang liegt die Frage auf der
Hand welchen Oligarchen und dieses Mal
kommt noch eine zweite Frage hinzu
welche Rolle sind wageners derzeitige
Führer bereit zu übernehmen schauen uns
doch das alles lieber mal etwas genauer
an
zerteile und
herrsche die wagnergruppe wurde am 23
August enthauptet an diesem Tag starb
brigosin doch mit ihm starben auch seine
beiden engsten Mitarbeiter seine rechte
Hand Dmitri utkin alias Wagner sowie
Valerie cekalov der für die gesamte
Logistik der wagnergruppe verantwortlich
war vielleicht wäre ihr Schicksal anders
verlaufen wenn sich pregorin an Putins
Pläne angepasst hätte in dieser Abfolge
von der essen sind die jeweiligen Daten
wichtig die geschalterte molterei fand
am 23 und 24 Juni statt am 29 Juni
schlug Putin bei einem Treffen im
Kremmel vor dass der ehemalige Oberst
Andrej troschev der neue Anführer
Wagners werden solle doch prgosin lehnte
ab und zog es vor mit seinen Söldnern
nach Weißrussland zu gehen er
vergrößerte sein Afron gegen Putin noch
indem er troschev am 30 Juni bei Wagner
feuerte wagnergruppe entlässt einem
ihrer fünf Anführer einen ehemaligen
Oberst der russischen Armee aus
verschiedenen Berichten geht hervor dass
troschev sich weigerte an der Wagner
mterei teilzunehmen und dass er den
Kremmel sogar von der von prigosen
angezettelten Rebellion gewarnt hatte
troschev ist ein pensionierter Oberst
ein Veteran der sowjetischen Invasion in
Afghanistan und der russischen Kriege in
cheetchenien er ist ein ausgezeichneter
Held der Russischen Föderation er war
offenbar prigoschins rechte Hand in
Syrien geworden und wir alle wissen wie
bestialisch Wagner in Syrien vorging
Putin wollte troschevs Loyalität nun
belohnen indem er ihm die Leitung der
Söldner Truppe selbst übertrog als wäre
Wagner ein weiteres Staatsunternehmen
aber als pregoog noch am Leben war
konnte er seine Entscheidung nicht
durchsetzen den Führer der wagnergruppe
per ordre der Mufti direkt zu ernennen
stellte bisher eine eher unangenehme
Option für den Kremmel da auch wenn man
bedenkt dass die Gruppe aus dem
staatsaushal finanziert
wird die direkte legale Verstaatlichung
der wagnergruppe liegt nicht wirklich im
Interesse Russlands dass dann seine
Beteiligung an den von Wagner begangenen
goldtaten nicht mehr leugnen könnte aber
die Frage ist natürlich ob dies nach
butcha und Mario Paul sowieso noch
irgendeinen Sinn macht dann wären da
aber noch die afrikanischen Potentaten
die gegenüber ihrer Bevölkerung
undosition leichter argumentieren können
es ist nun mal leichter zu behaupten
dass das Land noch unter ihrer eigenen
Kontrolle stehen würde wenn sie Söldner
anheuern und nicht Kräfte die direkt
ausländischen Staaten
unterstehen deshalb liegt die Vermutung
nah dass der Kremmel eher an einer
wagnergruppe oder an einer parallelen
Söldnertruppe interessiert ist die
zumindest auf dem Papier ihren
Ursprüngen ähnelt einer Gruppe von
Söldnern über die es viele Gerüchte und
wenige Gewissheiten gibt eine rücke in
den Schatten um eine plausible
abstreitbarkeit zu erreichen Poen hat
sich daher entschieden Wagner zu
selziieren es aufzuteilen so dass die
weltweiten Operationen unter einer für
das russische Verteidigungsministerium
günstigeren Führung fortgesetzt werden
könnten er will einfach nicht mehr alle
seine söldnereier in einen Korb legen
hier zuu heute sein man trochcheev
zunächst bei einem anderen privaten
Militärunternehmen an um dort
wagnersöldner einzugliedern Wagner raus
redut rein eine neue private
militärfirma entsteht in Russland unter
direkter Kontrolle des scbbels redut ist
dafür bekannt dass es die Sicherheit von
Infrastrukturprojekten in Syrien
gewährleistet hat diese wurden von
streutransgas durchgeführt einem
ingenieursunternehmen das mit dem Öl und
gassektor verbunden ist und von der
volggruppe des Oligarchen genadi
Timoschenko kontrolliert wird
interessant ist auch dass D nachdem sie
troschff angeuert haben versuchte auch
wagnerpersonal und erfahrene Kämpfer
anzuwerben um in der Ukraine zu kämpfen
bald könnte redut auch auf den
afrikanischen Kontinent expandieren denn
wenn man ein afrikanischer Führer ist
der bewaffnete Männer braucht ist es das
Letzte was einen interessiert ob auf den
Abzeichen redut oder Wagner steht
hauptsache es sind Söldner und keine
offiziellen russischen Soldaten so etwas
wurde bereits Ende Juni von einem
hochragigen Amtsträger der Regierung der
Zentralafrikanischen Republik in
Erklärungen gegenüber angence France
press geäußert die Zentralafrikanische
Republik hat ein verteidigungsabkommen
mit der Russischen Föderation und nicht
mit Wagner unterzeichnet russland hat
einen untervertrag mit Wagner
abgeschlossen wenn Russland nicht mehr
mit Wagner einverstanden ist wird es uns
ein neues Kontingent schicken alles
worum es Putin geht ist schließlich dass
er die Kontrolle über die min und
Bodenschätze in den Händen von
russischen Söldnern hält wer jetzt aber
denkt dass Wagner damit erledigt sein
der irrt denn nachdem torschef die
Strukturen bei redut aufgesetzt hat
kehrt er anschließend wieder an die
wagnerspitze zurück
wer ist Andrej troschev der neue Chef
des wagnerkonzerns das Medium
overclockers berichtete dass sich die
Miliz vor kurzem in der
Zentralafrikanischen Republik erneut
hervorgetan hat dort holte sie im
Auftrag der Regierung goldmienen zurück
die in die Hände von Terrorgruppen
gefallen waren die Zentralafrikanische
Regierung erkannte die Effizienz der
wagnerinfanteristen bei ihrem Mandat auf
dem Kontinent an diese Effizienz ist
nicht nur auf die Erfahrung der Soldaten
zurückzuführen sondern auch auf ihren
neuen Chef Andrej troschev der direkt
von Wladimir Putin ernannt wurde trosev
unterstehen n sowohl ehemalige Söldner
die sich wieder an der ukrainischen
Front befinden als auch die Truppen die
sich in Weißrussland befinden um die
Armee von Alexander lukasenka
auszubilden andere Teile der
wagenergruppe werden hingegen in die
russische Nationalgarde die Ros gardia
integriert und den Kommando Pavel
prigosin unterstellt und dieser Teil
rekrutiert nun auch wieder neue Männer
Wagner darf jedoch keine Häftlinge mehr
rekrutieren was vorher ja ihre
Spezialität war dies übernimmt nun
nämlich die russische Armee
selbst Putin kopiert Wagner Russland
rekrutiert Gefangene für den
ukrainekrieg russland hat das Steuer von
Wagner übernommen der Kremmel hat bis zu
100.000 Gefangene rekrutiert um in der
Ukraine zu kämpfen diese Praxis war ein
Markenzeichen des Verstorbenen
söldnerbosses jeevgeni brigosen der die
Reihen seiner Gruppe mit verurteilten
Kriminellen füllte die armeeeinheit die
gemeinhin als Storm Z bekannt ist wird
berichten zufolge als verfügbare Kraft
in Vladimir Putins militärischeer
spezialoperation gesehen mittlerweile
ist die Zahl der Gefangenen in der
russischen Gefängnissen von
schätzungsweise 420.000 auf etwa z 166
000 gesunken Putin hat auf Wagner also
seine erprobte Teile und
herrschstrategie angewandt wobei wir
hier eher von sowas wie zerteile und
Weide aussprechen können er hat die Best
Practices brigoschin einfach geklaut und
dafür gesorgt dass es ab jetzt keinen
großen söldnerstam er geben wird der ihm
gefährlich werden könnte allerdings soll
die wagnergruppe auch wenn sie in das
Kommando der regulären Armee integriert
wurde keine monolitische Organisation
sein viele Söldner hätten sich geweigert
jetzt unter Andrej troschew zu dienen
und würden nur auf die Befehle von Lotus
dem ehemaligen Stellvertreter Dimitri
utkins reagieren aber wartet mal einen
Moment denn Lotus sagt durch ja
vielleicht was war da nicht diese eine
Gruppe von widerspenstigen die prgosin
Tod Rechen wollten und sich einen neuen
Anführer gewählt haben der neue Warlord
der wagnergruppe wird enthüllt Lotus
übernimmt den Posten des söldnerbosses
Lotus ist nämlich der Name von Anton
elisarov auch bekannt als der Eroberer
von solida er war ein treuer Mitarbeiter
brigosens in den kompliziertesten
Szenarien wie Syrien und der Ukraine die
ganze Geschichte könnte also durchaus
noch etwas komplizierter werden aber wir
müssen realistisch sein die meisten
Söldner werden höchstwahrscheinlich eher
dazu neigen ihr eigenes Überleben zu
sichern als Putin zu trotzen indem sie
einem toten Führer die Treue halten
trotzdem was denkt ihr darüber glaubt
ihr dass die nachfolgestrukturen von
Wagner genauso erfolgreich sein werden
wie das von brigoschen aufgebaute
söldnerunternehmen oder hat Putin eher
dafür gesorgt dass der einztige
Kampfgeist des Söldner in mov Bürokratie
und Hierarchien erstickt wird ich hoffe
dass euch dies Video gefallen hat und
ihr dabei vielleicht auch was gelernt
habt falls ja gibt uns bitte ein Like
Fall mit neen Freunden und diskutiert es
auch mit Ihnen in diesem Sinne macht's
gut und bis
[Musik]
bald